я например форматы щекам сергея семплера
поздоровалась как как приличный человек
да ребят всем тоже кто не знает меня кто
пришел от могла макаревича тоже вам
привет мы сегодня будем общаться в общем
я почему хотел за хотел вас познакомить
со своей аудиторией в какой то момент я
наткнулся как и все на ваше видео
которых было просто заполонили интернет
и меня очень зашла тема касаемо кайдзен
планирование вот у меня за диван доска
ищет как раз и я сразу начал это
внедрять сразу начал рассказывать свои
аудитории горю ребята маргулан такой
мужик и общем очень много раз
рассказывал свои аудитории и поэтому
решил будет круто если вы прям сегодня
мы так с вами пообщаемся и вы как раз
дадите людям не знаю
долю своей мудрости наставления потому
что молодежь она реально в этом
нуждается народ потерянный особенно
сейчас и мне кажется для них вот
сегодняшнее то что вы скажете будет как
глоток свежего воздуха я надеюсь спасибо
большое очень рад познакомиться ещё раз
всем приветствую я вот единственно
сейчас сижу в наушниках и у меня
наушники работает с iphone а я одна и
она стоит на это переключить может быть
на компьютер чтобы запись обеспечить
потом ребятам качественную запись давай
я с тобой буду так общаться я извинюсь я
одна уж не переключу на до в общем я
пока скажу что если кто не в курсе они
сейчас мы не слышим
вообще звук пропал обучаться размер до
слышно попытаюсь громче говорить ну и
благодаря тому что или что и наушники
переключил на компьютер не можете
получить более качественную запись иду
на какой то что касается кайзен ты
знаешь меня сильно в этом мире поддержит
две вещи это религия и 2 к1
я к этому пришел достаточно давно казино
и прошел наверное 2 тысячи четвертом
году в религия пришел мне тоже прибегаю
я начал вот про верным
мусульмане 9 так то я после моей по
национальности он здесь не начал
выполнять все fortex целом это для меня
целый большой пласт философии
именно философия самосовершенствования
которое не имеет принципе пределов и
очень очень сильно помогает жизни просто
нереально сильно помогать жизни поэтому
когда пришло время но у меня начали
больше интересоваться не знаю сейчас
может время такое больше начали
спрашивать я с удовольствием начал
делиться этим плюс это конечно связано
еще с тем что я для себя в какой-то
момент принял такое правило в миссию
такси для чего я живу на этом свете и
моя миссия звучит так прожить эту жизнь
используете общества и окружающей среды
вот три вещи прожить счастливую жизнь
второе пользу обществу 3 и окружающей
среды соответственно я подумала как я
могу принести пользу обществу при этом
не нарушая счастье от своего дело в том
что человек не счастливый человек ничему
хорошему никого научить не сможет
поэтому вы должны сначала научиться быть
счастливым сама сами только счастлив и
человек может замотивировать научить
чему-то хорошему самое главное в этой
жизни чем может человек научит это
научить 0 быть счастливым и мне
понравился ты знаешь я в ислам пришел
интересно путем вёслами так и говорится
что путь богу у всех разный кто-то
приходит после катастрофы
кто-то приходит после семейных разлад
ссор кто-то там по другим причинам я
вниз нам пришел сугубо с рациональной
точки зрения
я до того как три киви снова у меня брат
давно с 2001 года исповедовал ислам и у
меня все время говорил ли он читает все
время религиозную литературу а так как я
очень активно занимался бизнесом плюс
кайдзен я периодически книгу приходил и
рассказывал проблему и он мне всегда
давал очень точные очень мудрые советы
а он ничего не читает кроме regret
литературы
а я читаю все я вот в этом плане комбайн
я просто читаю неимоверно к
лесок не каждый год при этом целую
методику на основе козинцев того как
правильно приобретать знания кстати в
моем youtube канале там есть
край галактики от 80 книг и тогда и меня
всегда удивляло и интриговала я его у
неё спрашиваю а как ты вот он гад но это
же все уже давно есть в исламе
я крыму как все может быть вёслами все и
начал изучать
начал изучать и убедился такую в такой
вещи что все правила казино практически
есть исламе но не все правила ислама
есть в кольцо
отсюда я понял что религия мусульманской
религии исламской религии она гораздо
шире и больше чем философия кайзен то
есть философия катина это кусочек от
исламской религии от excel и потому что
сама религия ислама она охватывает
помимо всех процессов эффективности
производства процессе так далее еще
очень много охватывать духовную сферу
социальную сферу там моральную сферам
так далее тогда и поэтому
но при этом между исламу и катя нам нету
ни единого противоречие поэтому я для
себя принял кольца на вооружение и это
бунтовать если в компьютеры не с ios и
microsoft две разные системы до есть еще
links to я для тех будет голову
установил это ислам плюс катин кайдзен
это как приложение несущая система софт
не существо это ислам вот таким образом
я пришёл к этой религии я таким образом
кайзен и вот таким образом я их вместе
связываю и одни друг друга только
укрепляют той волне помогает глубже
понять несла а ислам не помогает глубже
понять кольца вот все самое интересное
недавно приезжал один очень крутой гуру
я понесу один из основателей вообще
кальцием движения в японии и когда я
выступил я выступил и именно гору вы все
это была большая аудитория там куча была
производственников матерых директоров и
хозяев предприятий я когда начал делать
упор на
то чтобы руки ребята казино это прежде
всего философия а потом только
инструменты
ну и когда я выступил этот и для меня
было большой похвалой когда японские
куру подошел ко мне нас или и ты ко мне
в грудь говорит хи ноус фильмов skype то
есть шикане наши коня
хотя я очень мало там говорил про
методики про инструменты но пришел меня
прям круто call или переводится как
sinus-cosinus case то есть ему тоже
очень понравилось что именно философская
составляющая кальция основа то же самое
вёслами местами же тоже очень много
практически применимых инструментов как
женить людей как то что делать при
рождении детей при смерти кого-то там и
тогда ли т.д.
но это все инструменты за всем этим
стоит большая философия поэтому мне вот
интересный момент это то что вот вы к
этому пришли уже в осознанном возрасте
до там будучи от сколько вам было лет
получается от 30 до 35 где я в казино
это было 38 38 0 66 года
вот все что было до этого времени вот в
этот момент мне интересен потому что в
основном на 100 смотрит сейчас 2534 18
24 25 3 4 то есть это люди кто вообще
они даже не знаю такой кайдзен ок
религии у них вообще отношения сейчас но
мы это тоже позже обсудим мне интересно
ваше мнение будет но мне интересно
другое как вы считаете вот люди кто не в
курсе да я скажу что вы в свое время у
вас там было просто и сейчас как
мультимиллионер долларовые вас нам было
огромное состояние потом у вас все
отняли вы уехали из страны потом опять
вернулись ни у вас вот такой такая жизнь
эти взлеты и падения но мне интересно
где была вот это отправная точка то есть
потому что люди думают что успешными
рождаются да типа сразу богатые родители
там возможности и вот мне интересно вы
по себе как вы родились уже типа знаете
там со звездой во лбу я буду успешным
богатым или где-то был переломный момент
когда вы решили
типа все хватит хочу изменить свою жизнь
ты знаешь было это и то и другое дело в
том что я с детства когда я родился я
похоронила сам оптимист то есть понятно
этот фракталов вообще я так считаю что
давай я более фундаментальный отвечу на
этот вопрос смотреть когда человек
рождается по исламу говорится что
и чернила высохли и у каждого
предначертано судьба мне часто задают
вопрос как если судьба предначертано то
чего порваться можно надевали целый день
и сжатие всем на всё случится то что
случится в исламе говорится что двух
вещей человек не убежит от
предначертанной судьбы и второе бараката
или благо которая ему предписано там
есть еще судный день но вот это вот эти
вещи говорю да этот вопрос какой вот
представьте и я плюс еще отвечу на
вопрос смеси
человека когда large присылает нас на
землю он присылает на суда как
десантников сбрасывает на землю почему я
сейчас обосную вот представьте ребенок
она рождается у него характер откуда
точно не от воспитания второе у него
способности его талант и его темперамент
все это от аллаха это не от воспитание
нет школы ниоткуда потому что бывает там
дети
6 месяцев 8 месте уже показывает
характер и ты думаешь блин он еще
разговаривать не умеет уже характер свой
показывает cpa понимаешь что это точно
не от воспитания
сказать что только гены ну тоже не
скажет потому что умер часть характера
может быть от дедушки от бабушки вообще
не похоже и группами ненормальными отца
и так далее поэтому когда аллах нас
присылает на эту землю он нас при а нам
предначертал нашу судьбу
которую мы должны то есть судьба и то
есть миссия для чего на словах пришёл на
эту землю для того чтобы выполнить свою
миссию он также как десантника простота
десантник отправляешь куда-то джубе
тысячи что ему даешь нужное количество
патрон поверх ты даешь ему цель во
вторых то вершина то уничтожить
вражескую базу такую-то или сделать вот
такой такую-то вещь ты даешь ему нужно
количество патронов ты даешь ему нужное
обмундирование ты даешь ему бинокль и
ножи все что нужно и необходимо ровной
для выполнения этой миссии не больше и
не меньше даже больше вопросов большая
нагрузка он не выйти и дальше даже
меньше патронов он тоже ну там поэтому
даешь все ровно столько сколько ему
нужно сбрасывать на эту землю и человек
если он не выполняет миссию который
предначертано ему то он неэффективным в
этой жизни аллах его убирает из этой
жизни то есть он не будь счастливым он
не будет достигать своих целей и так
далее и здесь очень важно такой момент
понимать что когда мы приходим на эту
землю вот эти все способности и таланты
ты знаешь по исламу каждый человек
ответственным перед аллах будет отвечать
за свое тело за свои таланты и
способности тоже потому что это аманат
то что дали человеку за что он должен
нести ответственность для того чтобы
человек это все реализовал он должен мне
говорят есть выбор или нет выбор в чем
человек когда приходит на эту землю не
говорят вот я на диване и плату бежать
как я внесу свою буду выполнять я город
тонис можно этим одержать если твоя
миссия быть бегуном и не сможешь лежать
на диване у тебя просто ты не сможешь
просто тебя разорвет
ты не сможешь я хочется тепла будет
хотеться бежать способность тягу к
чему-то и любовь кто тебе дал это в
генах а кто в гены прописано to love
прям салоны
я хочу чтобы этот человек в этой жизни
добился стал таким то условно бегунов и
дал такой характер способность что ты
любишь пик что ты не можешь без бека что
ты грезишь и комбиком и до тебя до тебя
лежать на диване это пытка
соответственно вот эту любовь
способности склонности аллах уже заложил
и ты хочешь не хочешь будешь выполнять
эту миссию поэтому когда я родился я
родился оптимистом я родился
самоуверенно мне тоже самоуверенным
ребёнком я ничего не боятся плюс
родители слава аллаху у меня были такие
родители которые все время меня
поддерживали и говорили что я гений что
я он у меня мать общем ac4 братом от
себя говорил а у меня дома живут маркс
энгельс и ленин столики
4 она тебя одного ребенка назвал marcin
другом назвала индексом 3 лениным 4
сталин вы кем бы я так как 3 у меня
лениным называли братишка станет там бы
словно его
она все время говорила что мы крутые
чтобы великие она не когда родитель не
проверяли не проверять наши домашние
задания никогда ни разу школу не ходили
они всегда когда учить я ее спрашиваю
почему не приходите в школу мать всегда
говорила я знаю у моих детей все отлично
они у меня отличники ни разу не смог и
не посмотрев дневник и отец тоже был из
таких фигур людей который доверял
безгранично безгранично он знал что мы
не накосячим узнал что мы ответственные
люди и так далее и я вырос в атмосфере
высокого доверия я вырос в атмосфере
высокой самооценки самооценки и родители
это все время поддерживали поэтому здесь
первое это я родился таким второе
огромное влияние родителей и третье
после школы я напросился в комсомольском
одежду бригаду на постели баранов два
года все поехал поступать в универ и
близ тут а я как дурак поддался в
идеологии партийные дороге пошел баранов
пасти вот к концу второго
пел полтора года как папа с барана я
встретился с одним человеком который
посадили туда и на поселение он был
радиолюбитель кстати об этом написал
хороший пост в инстаграме тоже можете
посмотреть такая история такая
трогательная я посмотрел на него виду у
человека посадили на поселение он
продолжает вот это коротковолновой радио
делать и когда я гуру зачем тебе это
нужно
да брось ты же на поселить реже из-за
этого у суда посадили отняли у тебя все
семью там не так далее он зрение еще
было плюс 9 плохо видела группы зрения
на потерял в эту банку ты знаешь в чем
отличие человека баран игру не знаю
могут отличие только в том что у
человека есть цель у человека есть цель
и у человека есть миссия блоки все печи
кушаем одинаково в поле от выходим
одинаковым также состоит из белков
поэтому они хоть у меня все отняли но
моя свобода внутри меня не от этого не
стал менее свободным и вот прямо
следующий день сел на лошадь ходил был
зван людей там пас баранов но лошади в
какой-то меня момент мне топнула я
подумал неужели я родился на этот цвет
для того чтобы пасти свою еду и меня
перемкнуло я подумал нет ни фига и а не
для того вот на этот свет появился чтобы
пасти свою еду и с этого момента я
никогда ни разу не останавливаться в
своем саморазвитие а также не бывает
чтобы ни разу всегда же бывают моменты
когда думаешь а сегодня я не хочу жути
надоело как дал социальных момента
избрания
это вопрос такой если ты не занимаешься
любимым делом то тебе это надоест
а если ты занимаешься любимым делом то
это те никогда не надоест
дело в том что планирование оптимизацию
своей деятельности я по натуре сам ленте
а лентяй что дело о том всегда
придумывает способы как облегчить свою
работу но так как я лентяй
но в то же время ответственный лентяй
для меня важно было делать всегда
добиться цели
наименьшим приложением усилий и второй
момент никогда больше не выполнить эту
рутинную работу который умирает
соответственно я подходил творческие
всегда старался делать так чтобы работу
не выполнять дважды и если делать то не
спеша если белта качественно и с
наименьшим приложением усилий и вот лень
мне помогает все время в этом плане а с
другой стороны от чувства
ответственности и то что я занимаюсь
любимым делом не позволяет мне
заниматься прокрастинацией
то есть как бы такие как быть людям кто
вот-вот вам повезло да у меня тоже
родители слава богу они всегда меня тоже
поддерживали типа серёжа давай там ни в
чем не они не ущемляли я пробовал
детстве все там футбол баскетбол и так
далее а что делать людям и ко мне очень
часто пишут люди и обращаются этой
проблемы они говорят вот мне папа сказал
иди на юриста там и иди и медицинские
едины экономиста им вообще плевать на то
что хотят дети и ребенок в итоге он
выходит из школы поступает в университет
и у него уже зашорен а он вообще не
понимает а какая его миссия какая вот
цель как ему вообще надо понять ну на
что ему общественную жизнь потратить чем
заниматься как понять в чем его вот это
ключевая компетенция чем его аллах
наградил изначально как докопаться до
этой сути ну во-первых
родители надо уважать родители надо
любить
но не всегда слушать именно плане
касательно от своей жизни возьмите
ответственность за свою жизнь свои руки
мне родители никогда так не говорит и по
одной простой причине потому что я сам
всегда проактивно говорил что я буду
делать я всегда своим поведением
показывал что я справлюсь справлюсь я
всегда показывал что такое будь или мире
стал бы я добьюсь соответственно я
говорю бунтовать не оставлял им пустоты
до всегда пустота заполняется баком если
ты не берешь написан заслужил то
родитель да стоит ответственно за твою
жизнь здесь неизбежно то есть не бывает
так что там ребенок ведет себя
безответственно и родитель себя ведет
безответственно так не бывает
если родитель я как родитель сейчас
говорю если родитель видишь таран
ребенок у него немного одни
приспособлены безответственны то он
начинает
опекать своего ребенка это естественный
процесс вы должны прежде всего понять
родителей понять и простить как
говорится
понять простить и понять почему они вас
опекают почему они вам говорят о то тот
один значит вы допускаете и разрешает им
и показывайте свои поведением что вы не
полностью можете отвечать сами за себя
поэтому возьмите себе за правило всегда
чтобы в этой жизни с вами не происходило
прежде всего если хотите вырасти или
развиваться прежде всего вините во всем
себя кайдзен философия тоже говорит в 98
процентов всех косяков на предприятии
виноват не работник а виновата система
98 процентов вдумайся соответственно
японцы не наказывают работниках они
выясняют почему работник так поступил
почему он так сделал
исправляет систему и делать таким
образом что в следующий раз работник это
не может делать так же и с родителем
вините себя
поймите почему родители так поступает
почему вы должны сразу исключить такой
мид однозначно они вас любят потому что
вариант с родителями что они вас
ненавидят можно исключить однозначно не
это уже половина решения вопрос ты
знаешь что
основу них нет на мерене у них хорошие в
отношении вас это уже наполовину же
легко и дальше постарайтесь понять
почему они говорят поступить туда очень
часто родители готовят детей к своим
страхам прошлым страхом то есть опция
время не поступил или не получил
какую-то работу потому что не знал
английского языка
поэтому о пихает всячески чтобы ребенок
его знал английский язык то есть
родитель это как генералы
военные которая все время готовиться к
прошлым воинам они думают что следующая
война будет такой же как было прошлое
соответственно наращивают танки самолета
и так далее а будущего нет ни танки не
нужны ни самолета нужны такие родители
они готовят вас к своей прошлой жизни
там где они не смогли быть успешными они
хотят чтоб у вас этих skills of была
больше чем у них в то время
соответственно они же поделок из добрых
побуждений сядьте с родителями объясните
что в нынешнее время эти skills и
ненужные
либо объясняете что да я запланировал
я знаю ты хочешь чтобы я знал английский
языки либо финансы либо i wish столицу
у меня есть 2 на какого-то такого
периода я начну заниматься этим
самостоятельно но для этого не нужно
мушкет не нужен для этого инсту
но когда родители увидишь что ты
осознанный гражданин осознанно человек
учишь северске генцу финансы
там английский язык или чё там еще амир
успокоиться самое первое возьмите
ответственность за свою жизнь на себя
второе винить во всем себя
третье поймите почему родители
настаивают 4 объясните родителям что вы
берете ответственно себя и вы делаете
все что нужно для вашего же блага сейчас
модно еще вот я когда я все время тоже в
25 лет маму перевелся из томска
к себе в москву она там после развода
жила одна и я короче по тогда еще меня
тоже клинило я подумал все надо брать
ответственность мужик это тот кто берёт
ответственность и я взял мамы в 25 лет
снова начал с ней жить и и увидел как и
мама изменилось ли там стала счастливой
начала развиваться и я это к чему говорю
вот сейчас люди они думают так блин
поскорее бы 18 лет уехать в другой город
съехать от родителей и будет классная
свободная жизнь
но если мы посмотрим на опыт ваш опыт и
опыт других людей вот прокатить компании
мы почитаем то зачастую но так кроме
стива джобса это все люди очень семейные
которые очень были сплочены и семьи у
них они уважали родители и почитали их
вот все-таки
посыл для людей нет же ничего плохого в
том что ты там живешь с родителем я знаю
что вы до 40 лет по моему жили в одном
доме
мамой водка что вам дал дала вот это
друг дружная семья что она дает по факту
человеку почему надо поддерживать
родственные связи для и обрисовав до 40
лет мы практически даже больше наверно
жили не просто я с родителями жил в
маленьком доме здесь поселок путь
отличались мы жили там все четыре брата
с женами с детьми
все жили уже моим братьям под 50 лет
было мы все продолжали жить вместе ну не
50 45 там и так далее но это конечно
основная заслуга было нашей матери и
нашего
мы как-то легко легко так жили и
нам это реально очень сильно помогало ну
какой то мы жили общей дружной семьей и
у нас в менталитете мы должны они
собирались и не хотели жить отдельно но
это конечно заслуга родители они создали
среду такую атмосферу и естественного
заслуга наших жен которые терпели это
все боевая там всех держала в узде так
стоять и так далее поэтому но
преимуществ на самом деле очень много ко
мне обращается очень много бизнесменов
молодых которые например должны принять
какое-то важное решение и мне не с кем
посоветоваться почему потому что
одноклассником они не доверяют
коллегам тоже ног подозревают что ну а
не к этому времени уже ветка под
лопаткой что их покидали и не с кем
посоветоваться и они проходят там со
мной советоваться там я все могу
посредством времени не хватает на все но
в это время если бы были бы родные люди
то можно вот например получить хорошие
советы подискутировать иногда человеку
просто важно даже не услышать хороший
совет а вслух проговорить проговорить
проблему вслух и когда ты проговариваешь
не пытаешься объяснить свою проблему
человеку который в этом не разбирается
то ты сам приходишь к пониманию своей
проблемы как ее надо решить потому что
как правило человек который мне в теме
он задает глупые вопросы условно гнутый
там детские вопросы а почему зачем это а
что ты так не сделаешь и ты начинаешь
точного чудят были тут и кун и тоже в
общем то есть у меня к счастью всегда в
этом плане есть браке а мы с ними
общаемся по всем этим вопросам и это
очень сильно поднимает
помогает принимать правильные решения в
жизнь вся наша жизнь состоит из
правильного время принятых тройных
решения вот смотрите есть такое правило
вид если вы хотите посмотреть как вы
принимали решили прошлом посмотрите на
сегодняшние ваше состояние если вы
хотите узнать как
в будущем вас ждет посмотрите на ваши
текущие действия очень важно четко
понимать поэтому правильно принятии
решений так что то завес
так не то есть понятие то я зависели а
вот все
не у меня входящий звонок а как вы на
плане семья очень сильно помогает
поэтому очень нужно чтобы иметь человека
с кем можно общаться это может быть жена
это может быть брата это даже можно с
родителями обсуждать и так далее семья
очень сильно помогает потому что ты по
крайней мере не подозреваешь них
патентов потому что у тебя собираются
кинуть завидовать и так далее много до
таких вещей убираются
а помните какой то совет прям такой от
отца и от мамы которого прямо в ту же
запала вы его потом всю жизнь вспоминали
думали джолин вот мама была права но я
думаю один из основных советов наверно
мне отец дал мне отец он прошел войну в
тридцать девятом году ушел на финскую
потом 40 первую в армию призвали
димитрис девятом 18 признали потом сорок
первом на немецкий фронт пошел
фашистский фронт там воевал закончил
войну еще два года был коменданта города
в польше и он не странную на тот момент
я не понял фразу сказал как мардан
никогда не бойся войны в конце война
всегда приносит благ я так как война
может приносить никак не понимал но и
сейчас кстати я размышляю над продолжал
размышлять над этим но вот этот совет
нет дал какую-то
вечную верность что после любого кризиса
будет благ после любая поэтому не боюсь
кризисов я не боюсь там каких то падение
так далее мне многие задают вопрос как
не почему все время встаете игру ну во
первых не по-настоящему никогда я не
подаю никогда не то что экономическая
просадка это нормально главное вдохом не
упасть то есть четко человечек с
побежденным только тогда когда он сам
признал себя побежденным все остальное
время это просто о наступлении
[музыка]
любой ваня или с нападение есть
отступление это вполне нормальная вещь
поэтому вот недаром же все более
заканчиваю только тогда когда для пони
направили пирата подписал акт о
капитуляции германии когда проиграла
тоже акт о капитуляции
но фигов просто
победитель его к капитуляции нафига там
у тембру проиграешь пройдешь нет нужно
закончить войну для этого нужно от пакет
капитуляции поэтому такая люди сами себя
не признают пораженным побежденным они
не никогда не проигрывают паки здесь у
меня это слово отца что морган война
всегда в конце приносит благо она запала
и я в святаго кодирование там не из
прямо много раз помогала и я потом
много раз убеждался и вёслами всегда
говорится что аллах вас испытывает и
после испытаний всегда приходит блага
облегчения на а вот тогда еще такой
вопрос вот если мы говорим про религию
да мы знаем что человек должен
обходиться малым ну по возможности в
идеале и что любая привязанность которая
есть у человека на его будет мучить и
как вы тоже в своем интервью говорили
когда вы купили себе марс и летите в год
мы об этом на следующий день его разбили
зато есть наши наши привязанности они
всегда нас испытывают и как в себе
примирить амбиции
с убеждениями как правильно хотеть стать
успешным заработать много денег но при
этом и не хотеть стать успешным
заработать много денег вот этот
внутренний конфликт между убеждениями о
том как должно быть и как мы хотим как
это вот примирить в себе какое-то дело
иисуса здесь очень важно понимать такую
вещь не если вы хотите что то для себя
то скорее всего чем больше вы чего-то
хотите тем меньше шансов чтобы вы это
получит и если вы это хотите делать ради
аллаха либо
ради блага людей что все равно
равнозначно что ради аллаха тогда у вас
это будет получаться и ваше хотение
будет помогать ты понимаешь и сами же
что говорится если мойра
будет преследовать блага этого мира то я
сделаю так что блага власть и слава
будут убегать от него
но если преследовать блага того мира то
я сделаю так что власть и деньги и слава
будут бегать за ним как собачки с чем
дело все зависит от намерения от
намерения ради кого ты собираешься
что-то сделать из литых
she ради себя ради своего золотого
унитаза заработать побольше бабла то
скорее всего у тебя это не получится
если ты хочешь облегчить жизнь людей
придумать какой-то продукт который
облегчит либо сократит расходы либо
создаст удобства для людей то скорее
всего ты заработаешь много денег богатый
человек все зависит от намерений от
набери теперь возвращаясь к моменту
довольствоваться малым
нельзя воспринимать это фактически то
есть вот есть условно 100 долларов и вы
должны больше все нет каждый человек для
каждого человека малая это имеет разную
величину
зависимости от размера и сознания
человека для кого-то 100 долларов малая
для кого-то 100000 долларов
мало аллах и ислам не против богатства
потому что богатство распределяется
самим замахом и топоры как поэтому
довольствоваться надо не столько малом а
сколько необходимо все время авиценна
сказал все что лишнее таят все что лично
но для кого-то мерз это не личная не
лично я почему потому что но в разные
ситуации бывают у stone а вот я много в
походы ниже для меня там я купил тойота
там тон труда навороченный toyota tundra
ремонта на уазике ездит но нет я во
первых очень часто езжу во вторых мне
нужна надежная машина но и много
характеристики так далее соответственно
не окупился toyota tundra plus могу себе
позволить
но это тоже не излишества это не
излишества я же мне не поставил
новогоднюю елку с игрушкой там всем
функционально все нужно все необходимое
каждая лебедка и спереди и сзади я знаю
для чего стоит до чего-то полные баки
для чего большие колеса дорогие стоят
такси вот узнаю это необходимость
поэтому уровень довольство малым это не
значит что в удовольствии реально там
мало
это говорит для каждого человека вот это
понятие мало и мало разное другой вопрос
что я говорю все зависит от того как вы
заработали деньги с каким намерением
есть и у вас правильное намерение то вам
придут скорее всего правильные деньги
который от вас цепь неудач я земли вышел
на протяжении всей своей жизни заметил
все деньги которые мне легко пришли или
пришли условно говоря неправедным путем
они быстро точно также исчезни исчезли и
в то же время есть бизнеса на которую я
не делал ставку и считал их геморрой
ними они меня до сих пор кормят то есть
здесь в момент такой нужно вот такие
моменты чирка учитывать люди сами по
себе очень сильно переоценивают свой
разум
я кстати хотел бы еще такой момент
сказать вот люди спрашивают зачем бог 21
век да я гуру вот смотрите вот есть
уровень животных до животных что есть
животное это биологический организм
который управляет определенными
алгоритмами алгоритмы это инстинкты то
есть если собаки холодно она идет на
солнцепеке лежит танки тепло у него
алгоритм струны не лижи не терпи и на
холоде идей там где тепло
иначе умрешь нам это простейший организм
алгоритм нести собака даже не понимает
почему она туда идет она просто идет и
все там где тепло
дальше идет человек выше животного но
человек существо разумное у которого он
думает что он ученую круто и так далее
он может просчитать на два шага вперед
операх понимает почему ему холодно он
понимает почему им надо 1 отчетного
сторону реки и он понимает выстраивать
дорожку понимает как тратьте и когда
добила доходит до теплой стороны вам
поговорить я крути и крутая поставим
цель я достиг
третий уровень это человек который
то есть человек это тот существо которое
мало того что может пользоваться
алгоритмами алгоритмами собаки или из
животных больше можете выстраивать
самостоятельно алгоритмы как действовать
разных ситуациях но как действует сразу
ситуацию для того чтобы эффективно
действует ты должен предугадывать как
работает сама вселенная законы вселенной
по подписи брать знание людей знания
людей вот такие собаки там вообще так .
вот такие но вселенная огромна гораздо
больше чем знают люди а раз вселенная
гораздо большая вселенная и жизнь
гораздо больше чем вы знают люди значит
эта вселенная работаешь по каким-то
законам которую нам неведом так вот эти
закалена приоткрывает завесу
приоткрывает религия религия говорит вот
есть условно 10 грехов
убьешь конце это тупиковая ветвь
алгоритм всегда это приводит к несчастью
своему несчастью
так изнасилуешь всегда привод не сейчас
воруешь в себя приводки сейчас в это все
запомните это все тупиковые способы
действий то есть тупиковый алгоритма не
делайте их не судить и не будете судимы
там тебя сделали плохо отток нехорошим
это все все сломать религии то есть
человеку даются дополнительные алгоритмы
как поступать чтобы прожить счастливую
жизнь и когда вас прислал нам куран он
пишет я прислал это писание для того
чтобы облегчить вашу жизнь не не аллаха
жизни вашу жизнь чтобы обличье он
предстал
так вот когда все время еще до принятия
снова брату приходил груз лучше если
соблюдать все заповеди то у тебя нету
врагов тысяч если вы там ни о чем не
закончена давайте говорить весь вес рай
на земле это люди из и своими страстями
делаю так править на этой земле то есть
если ты не добьюсь не достиг края на
этой земле то бесполезно рассчитывать
что ты там будешь про не понимаешь в чем
фокус
то есть прежде чем стать это как пример
знаешь как если ты мысленно эмоционально
ментально не стал богатым то ты не
станешь
деньги к тебе не приду то есть значит
сейчас много коучинг представь чтобы ты
у тебя уже есть деньги представив сотни
же я богат и они приедут только верхнюю
оболочку поверхность только на самом
деле ты должен изменить менталитет если
ты хочешь стать богатым эти хочет
доказать свою
закон закон эйнштейна есть вы никогда не
решите проблему находясь на том же
уровне на котором у нее создать
соответственно религия позволяет уйти на
следующий уровень благодаря этому уровню
и соблюдайте заповеди ты понимаешь вот
эти тупиковые пути так не задействуя так
нельзя действовать
просто даже если будешь соблюдать их не
вникая ты уже имеешь преимущество перед
многими людьми сразу сходу и оси будешь
вникать еще в философию ты можешь
предугадывать ты можешь читать знаки
этой вслед и ты можешь понимать какое
дело надо действовать с каким намерением
и что говорит что делать интересно и на
самом деле ты понимаешь что в мир так
крутиться не по законам только физики
ведь не каждый физик объясню вернее
физики вообще не смогут объяснить что
такое сглаз что такое закон подлости вот
я же целый направлений закон паркинсона
теории вероятности теория игр
там и так далее которые мало поддаются
научному объяснению
но они существуют у китайцев мне
нравится хорошее выражение есть такое
понятие
знание без слов и они говорят вот так
вот так вот так будет когда-то у не
спрошу почему они как не знаю понимаешь
они как просто ли у них есть такой
термин знание певцов и групп почему
когда спросишь почему так считать
суббота выбрать не знаем но я знаю
что-то будет
понимаешь на бесплатные
дается этому объяснение просто никогда
не каждый человек это этом уверен там ну
условно даже простой по приметам мой
друг одну пришел говорит мой сын сейчас
исповедовать ислам всякую чушь говорить
такую какую чушь и может быть но говорит
папа нижнего рукой на левой руке шайтан
себя кушай правой рукой какие шампань и
принты как это как на левой руке я
группы своему другу ты понимаешься
вопрос вам про просто не правильно
объяснил вот у меня есть компания
птицефабрики там мы номер один продлится
казахстан куриного мяса до у нас четко
птичника разъем грязных дорога чистая
дорог
по чистой дороге приводят только к армян
по грязной пороге в образе вывозят помет
и так далее так далее не эти дороги на
протяжении пятнадцати километров не
должны пересекаться
так вот представь саудовской аравии там
раньше они шли до в бой как он куда-то в
поход в караван и так далее нету воды
естественные надобности надо справлять
если ты у тебя этого правила не будет то
когда ты станешь кушать с другими людьми
с общего котла ты не знаешь какая рука у
тебя чистая потому что не помнить какой
рукой что держал ощути оправил что левая
рука всегда грязные ты справляешься
нужды левой рукой то ты смело садишься и
пушить правой рукой потому что ты знаешь
что ты никак никак не мог прикоснуться
грязным вещам правой рукой потому что у
нас всегда право и лево и всегда грязно
и чтобы объяснить
неграмотным людям просто листами четко
говорится на левой руке всегда шейка но
это же практика это практичность
понимаешь если бы в религии вёслами были
да что-то не практично будешь и ленивые
существа они давно забыли в это правило
выкинули бы то правило из употребления
ну раз это все сохраняется значит в этом
есть глубокий смысл
а вот вы говорите допустим вот 38 лет вы
начали кайдан назначать и потом уже
более углубленно в религию но свои-то
миллионы яхты и вертолет вы получается
заработали до того как как скажем так у
вас появилась выше миссии цель то есть
что-то до этого
что двигало вами дело в том что я да это
у меня не первый подъём не первое
падение
у меня было много несколько кризисов что
я считаю дала религиями и
и кальцием ты дальше вот у меня есть
такое правило мастерство мастерство не
не столько улучшает результат сколько
стабилизирует это первый правило второе
каждый раз когда ты делаешь в рамках
казино и для ислама то ты при падении
терпишь меньше убытка меньше ущерба при
росте зарабатываешь больше то есть это
какой-то к и он не к 1 и ислам это не
значит что у твоей жизни уйдут кризис
нет это испытание которые аллах
периодически присылает простаты на
каждом падении теряешь меньше а на
каждом роте заработаешь больше вот что
дает и и строим и contain the этого я
зарабатывал много всего но также
благополучно до дна все терял понимаешь
вот в чем разница то есть если до этого
у меня была вот такая пила вверх вниз
вверх вниз вверх вниз
0 100 000 100 то сейчас у меня ноль 120
120 40 140 ну как бы общий тренд вверх
на эту дату чем просто интересно шла из
greevil а с 1 0 до сотки какая была
мотивация явно не помощь людям же нет то
время мотивация была так страна развалил
советский союз и нам sky более
зарабатывайте деньги сейчас как харизма
а я прочитал менял основная книга была
было терпкая тур драйвер тревоги желаний
финансиста титаника финансист стоек ну
тревоги и мне очень нравился главный
герой фрэнком pierdut я зарабатывал
максимально так так могу в рамках закона
и ну как меня это успешно получалось
я достаточно хорош в коммуникациях
вообще
там плюс но понимание моток момент то
наверно больше чем у других было
понимание родину рыночных основах потому
что я когда университете учился я
изначально понимал что я буду бизнесмен
я понимал не хотел быть бизнес нами то
есть у меня четкая цель была ты знаешь
несс очень важно понимать что прежде
всего чтобы говорит вообще в любом
успехи прежде всего надо продлится если
у тебя цель если у тебя цели нету то у
тебя никогда не будет успеха
вот как китайские пословицы хорошо
говорит у корабля у которого нет цели
никогда не бывает попутного ветра и вот
понятие эффективность для того чтобы
действовать эффективность
эффективно не бывает простой
эффективности эффективность всегда идут
в сравнении с чем-то и относительно
чего-то ты не можешь быть эффективным
просто так ты можешь только быть
эффективным в отношении цели либо в
сравнении статус с кайратом маратом с
кем-то
то есть эффективность либо определяется
либо сравнительным методом либо по
отношению к цели россию тебя цели да как
ты определишь и эффективный то
неэффективны в данном случае ты страницы
с кем-то не может потому что у каждого
человека разные цели если бы у вас были
бы как на беговой дорожке две одинаковые
дорожки и там можно определить
эффективность по отношению в другом
бегуны но всех людей же разные цели
соответственно в отношении кого то ты и
свою эффективность проверить не можешь
ты можешь ее по измерить только
папашиной свои цели цель
самое главное с чего все начинается если
у тебя есть эта цель то ты можешь
добиться успеха при этом цель состоит из
двух видов целей одна цель это результат
а вторая цель это процесс и очень много
меня кстати с 90-х годов все время
назвали я когда общался с бандитами они
все говорили всегда говорили ты процесс
никто не держит
результативны интересно что у них было
такое понимание да но я потом понял
тоже что преследование правильного
процесса это кольца
это ислам а результат это а вот западная
система когда американцы дважды мне под
еще ты делаешь как ты делаешь это
результат с ударным правильно это
неправильно и если ты ставишь цель
заработать деньги на дом то больше
вероятно что ты это не добьешься а если
ты поставил себе цель процесс то есть
заниматься каким-то делом качественное
лучше всех а то скорее всего ты
заработаешь на то понимаешь очень просто
как цель ставить процесс они результа
поэтому когда я говорю найдите свое
любимое дело заниматься любимым делом и
на гору тогда ставьте целью процесс я
себе ставил целью не заработать деньги
на дом на машину тогда я стоял свою
целью заниматься бизнесом и быть лучшим
бизнесменам все вот мои была цель я
вообще не парился по поводу денег
конечно не просто приходили и приходили
приходили нужно по фактам то есть по
факту есть на человек ограничивается
только целью грубо говоря материальной и
у него нет вот вот этой высшей цели да
какая то он по-любому придет к
разочарованию как вот есть звезды
шоу-бизнеса там один повесился элвис
пресли там от передоза умер то есть это
же закономерность когда люди только
одержима вот этим они по-любому потом
приходит к разочарованию правильно это
всегда достижение любой цели это как
гора когда ты ноль и не отойдешь ты
пойму что та сосна турфирма трава не
зеленее
ты всегда достижение какого-то успеха
для чего за собой разочарование видит
единственный случай когда это не
приводит к разочарованию если ты
занимаешься процессом то есть любимым
делом она нескончаем ты не можешь
закончить придти каком-то это
промежуточный процессом и так проходит
дома шириной а то и так далее а ты все
идешь ты занимаешься любимым делом
бизнеса либо инвестирование либо еще
чем-нибудь на музыка и так далее важно
концентрироваться на процессе важно
хотел быть лучшим мастером своем деле
вот я помню
мне нравится понятия шакуни на шо кунин
это есть человек который стремится быть
лучшей в мире вот если он пришел
дворником он не хочет быть начальником
отдела дворников директором корпорации
горника он хочет быть лучшим дворником в
мире он может быть лучшим поваром в мире
вы может быть лучшим плотником в мире
понимаешь это когда у достигнутого
мастерства восстановится шоку ни на что
пунин этот мастер тогда ты будешь
счастливым человеком тогда ты никогда не
общего с разочарования тогда ты никогда
то что ты сказала премьер чтобы не
случается да нам сейчас надо будет
перезапустить эфир потому что уже час мы
общаемся чтобы иначе он вырубится ребят
предупрежу я сейчас запущу с новые серии
добавлены новые
после эфир маргулана а слышно будет не
слышно
а меня слышите сейчас вы слышали про
наши ребята пишут типо звука нет звука
не слышно пишут обычно теперь норм
вариантов лично тебя еще комменты
вот еще комментарии ты только дуплексов
и за да да я просто перезапустил потому
что там и еще и звука не было по этой
причине вот но интересно интересно вот
еще такой вопрос вот сейчас модно из-за
того что институт брака институт семьи
сейчас целенаправленно просто
разрушается вот так шаг за шагом и
раньше женщин не думал о том что я надо
работать она думала вот придет муж да
там допустим если мы возьмем по исламу
возьмет ее в жены и будет содержать
будет ответственность за свою пас вы
будете заботиться и делать все что
полагается то сейчас времена изменились
и женщина сидится думать блин даёте
понимаю уже сидеть на месте я должна
зарабатывать и чаще всего вот
бизнес-вуман они несчастны как вы
думаете почему так происходит почему
когда женщина уходит с головой в деньги
она теряет в отношениях с мужчинами
то есть не может встретить потом своего
там мужа
будущего из магазинов что должно быть
главное в мужчине чтобы в итоге как бы
что самое главное в мужчине должно быть
и что самое главное в женщине на по
качествам ты знаешь то что касается
зарабатывает денег я понимаю феминисток
они хотят быть наравне с мужиками но как
правило феминистки это незамужней
женщины ты знаешь есть такое хорошее
правило
атеиста 1 встряски самолете коммунист до
1 капитала феминистская до хорошего
парня то есть как она встретить хорошего
парня выйдет замуж она не датами не до
феминизма тесто вопрос такой что если
женщина стремится зарабатывать деньги то
здесь надо задать правильный вопрос для
кого зарабатывать то есть зарабатывать
при весе день для кого цель
это себя зарабатываем должно же иметь
цель мужчина это делать для содержания
семьи женщина
если она собирается это делать для
содержали все дни а кто рожать дело в
том что машина создал всех разными ну
комп принципе близкий чтобы не говорили
ну я не слышал еще может быть истории
есть когда мужчина родил ребенка на
лепку детей рожает женщинами переход за
пиво низко там 200 кем-то нас это закон
природы
отсюда вывод смотри давай посмотрим на
роль мужчины и женщины как устроена
физиология физиология устроено так что
мужчина он осеменяет как можно больше
женский пол этой они будут не только
пропущено про животных тоже у нас так
создал поэтому у него миллиарды
сперматозоидов и он семинар разбрасывает
у женщин вниз великая миссия только
женщина определяет будущее человечества
потому что только женщина решает какому
мужчине дать шанс оставить свое
потомство
то есть она выбирает из многих мужчин
которые по ней бегают
1 берет за него цепляется и от него
урожай все и соответственно так как
женщина рожает то естественно есть
период когда беременности есть период
скапливается вскармливание есть люк
воспитанием логическому в этот период но
какой бизнес
какой бизнес если в этот период женщина
будет думать не а ребенка бизнес и то
она потеряет с с ребенком у него
некачественное семья будет она потеряет
мужа и в результате она разрушает эту
ячейку это же ячейка такая клетка
общество который происходит таинство
размножения она это потеряет и в конце
маска станет бизнес у младшей но без
семьи либо с ребенком стала у которой
нет ни у него нету контакта со своим
ребенком то есть ну чудес не происходит
как бы они не пытались говорить что не
надо совмещать работу и воспитание и
рожай одитинге быть хорошей женой и так
далее
ну это может быть исключение какой-то
может быть но это исключение может
только подтвердить правил то есть 99 9
процентов скорее всего пара дней
получится поэтому я не то чтобы против
есть женщина одиночка одинокая туда надо
зарабатывать надо себя содержать
если ее бросил можно надолго или там
разве тетка понятно заниматься работать
содержать выйти ты замужем
если у тебя брат счастливый то как
бизнеса твой главный клиент это твой муж
шествие главный клиенты там их если ты
сумеешь держать мужа счастливым то
повергните не надо париться по поводу за
работники
сам счастлив члена чтобы доказать свою
мужественность
ободе рамок мужчина только для этого и
создан он добытчик поэтому они htr что
вот ту женщину основное качество должен
будет это доброта это на верность это
милосердие это мягкость это основные и
при смене режима они женщины лучше видят
риски
они их основной функции то сохранить
деньги не заработать они у них лучше
получается когда они занимаются
сохранением денег у друга и про что если
так уж приспичило
и нужно чтобы она занималась бизнесом то
лучше всего когда мужчины зарабатывать
деньги и дают ей и она дальше решает что
делать на банковский депозит или валюту
хранители дом охранять или к там куда-то
что-то разместить и т.д.
вот в плане удержание денег женщины
круче мужиков плане
зарабатывание денег мужчины лучше женщин
ну я гору в общей массе чтобы меня не
сожрали низкий а вы тоже крутые но в
целом листы брать то такое распределение
это происходит естественно мудрому
почему потому что чтобы заработать
предложенный кино многие рискованные
вещи ты должен брать риск на себя ты
должен летать
другие города встречаться с неизвестными
мужиками
я не представляю как мужчина сидит дома
его жена есть другие города и
встречается с неизвестно мужиками якобы
но не то что я кампус колледжа реально
ведет переговоры вот они дело
я что это однозначно разрушить семью
паять за ревность и так далее то есть
мужик должен брать риск на себя
а если он не берет виновата женщина это
мужчины или обуви на али ты дальше здесь
момент такое котом же как я прародители
говорил если женщина стремится
зарабатывать деньги то значит мужчина в
чем-то дает слабину
помощи открыл винить надо всегда себя
почему твоя женщина хочет заработать
почему кароч ты не то заработаешь значит
пыли не доказывает что ты делаешь все
понимаешь в отношении женщиной важные то
сколько ты приносишь не зарабатываешь
сколько то она должна видеть как ты
стараешься аккордеон
вот это очень важно когда в указах есть
такая пословица на гантели
астроном kansas ханурик то есть это
говорит мне важно не то что ты готовишь
а важно как ты суетишься поэтому вот это
очень важно понимать месте твоя женщина
хочет зарабатывать деньги то это может
быть две причины у вас достаточно много
денег и она мается от безделья
частота женщины богатых людей пытались
но это и дальнюю игрушка просто выделить
деньги лимитирован чтобы она не могла
проходить все
дай определенную сумму иска делай что
хочешь а второй вариант если у вас нету
лишних денег она хочет заниматься
бизнесом значит ты не зарабатываешь и
никто не что зарабатывание больших денег
в плане того что ты не убедил ее в том
что ты прилагаешь максимум усилий что-то
за риска опять
видимо опять наверно позволь позвонили
сейчас дождемся звонок давид это не
забыл чё-то мне написали что
так тогда такой момент вот сейчас люди
они вот боятся в брак вступать и мужик
думает вот сейчас я сначала на ноги
встану а потом женюсь йонатан на ноги
может вставать там год 2 5 10 то есть
все таки как лучше вот если ты встретил
человека и ты понимаешь что ты увидел и
понял что все да там не буду мозги
делать все груженый там все как положено
или же он думы были мне сначала надо
прям заработать много бабла и только
потом но здесь надо четко понимать что
заработать много бабла этого зависит не
столько от человека сколько тура
он баррикад он распределяет и это может
никогда не случится или может быть
другой вариант
далек от может прийти именно после того
как ты женщина потому что аллах за
каждым человеком дает свой барокко и
может быть именно порог от твоей жены
дался откроет тебе дорогу поэтому я
всегда молодым говорю жениться надо не
тогда когда ты готов а тогда когда
встретил правильного человека только
единственный критерий неважно что у тебя
ни копейки денег нет неважно вы всегда
можете процессы заработать если ты нашел
правильного человека у тебя может дорога
открыта везение может начаться полоса
везения наш может быть она и есть первый
предвестник твои полосы визит встретить
праведного человека поэтому вообще не
палились я не верю понятие планирования
семьи планирование детей это на самом
деле от шайтану потому что
люди таким образом думают что они
чего-то в этой жизни планировать могут
но час коронавирус нам же показал что
без мир ни хрена ничего планировать не
может какой-то несчастный мир не rus
которого никто в глаза не видел
по-настоящему ты видела я тоже мы но мы
все боимся мы все боимся на сидим по
домах миллиарды и триллионы долларов
убытками верпир ты из-за какого-то
коронавируса которым никто в глаза не
видел поэтому там планировать на этом
фоне что-то считать что ты чудо
добьешься это это все тупит и какой
тогда
индикатор я вот обычно как думаю что
здесь должна быть совокупность грубо
говоря
и сердцем и разумом потому что если вы
perish только сердцем отбывает человек
там все в голову вобьет там не больная
конец влюбленность и он идет против
семьи против всех итоге по-другому крах
церковь и вот есть смотри ты вопрос до
этого забыл когда жениться эти ответы
а вот как выбирать как выбирать я тоже
молодым говорю дело в том что вот указав
есть свое процедуры как любят но я много
оттуда взял я например считаю что
девушка к его растет оно в течение всей
жизни все равно будет подражать тому что
она видела в детстве то есть своей
матери поэтому прежде чем жениться
обязательно посмотри на ее мать указав
вес так вот освоиться
поздно лорду через на то есть внутри
данной потому что именно такой она в
конце путь поэтому посмотрим а мать
приветливая или а на него штыревая и так
дори тогда это 1 момент 2 момент
обязательно смотреть если у нее подруги
если блога подруг то плохо желательно
чтобы их было мало лучше чтобы совсем
почему потому что когда подруги выскочит
замуж на других людей они неизбежно
будут хвастаться друг перед другом у
меня сумочка такая у меня дошло до с и
ты всю жизнь будешь соревноваться с
мужьями своих подруг вот этот огня это
очень важно и будешь всю жизнь
соревноваться с мужьями подруг
поэтому в этом плане смотри на много или
мало тут хорошо
у неё много подруг при том же да тогда
смотри о чем они говорят и какое у них
устремление если они говорят только
шмотках то ничем хорошим это не
закончится лучше тогда сразу своей
избранные сказать давай так ты до меня
замуж выходишь и я буду для тебя лучшей
подругой я твоя подруга и давай то есть
поэтому смотришь на мать смотришь на
подруг смотришь на то о чем говорят
подруги
если девушка выбирает парня на что она
должна смотреть она должна смотреть
откуда родом парень то есть кек кем он
является сейчас
и кремом хочет быть мужика оценивать
можно только в динамике только в
динамике кем он был и мост является со
стеклянного получат и вот это очень
важно есть у него хорошая динамика если
он был в захолустном там мухосранске
потом сейчас живет в алмате
снимает квартиру но у него есть работа и
он хочет поступить гарвард ясно
парень с амбициями с хорошей динамики и
у него получается это первыми второй
момент обязательно посмотреть на друзей
своего мужа почему потому что истина
воспитании девочки влияет пример ее
матери то на воспитание мальчика влияет
только улица не отец отец никак не
влияет на воспитание ребенка
кроме как своем пример в основном он все
равно
подвержен три яруса и друзей и улице
поэтому смотри какие у него друзья здесь
леваде друзья говорят на шмотках а вот
эту всякой фигне то скорее всего этот
так далеко не уйдет скорее всего я
подчеркну не сто процентов скорее всего
потому что сальто все равно не
отпускается их людей если он начнет
перестань бухать мач но там учиться и
его затекут скажи ты чё платан что лето
но начнут по всякому человеку
поэтому скорее всего вернется в среду но
бывает исключение вырываются поэтому а
взять посмотри на его друзья
на динамику друзей о чем они говорят и
четвертый момент когда вы убираете парня
очень важно смотреть парень должен быть
щедрым
это основное свойство мужчины если у
меня говорю что мужчина основной
добытчик то какой нафиг он добытчика
если он эгоист
он равен sin а только добывание поэтому
парень должен быть щедрым
щедрость от на основное качество мужчины
щедрости белгородцев два основных
качества ну и третье это амбиции
стремление к большему вот три основе
качество стремление к большему
щедрость и благородство ясно на качество
и богу прайме у мужчин поэтому это я к
тому говорю что если вы сможете
разглядеть но как правило влюбленные
люди
это слепые люди завеса была была горяча
пробиться такое что замуж выдавали или
же ними родители потому что они видят
что двух молодых друг другу тянут и
родители идут и в это время смотрят на
матируем там и так далее тогда ты знаешь
статистика показывает что когда родители
женят детей браке чаще отмечаются
удачными нежели неудачным чем когда дети
появляются и на основе любви женится это
объяснимо еще такой момент иметь во
многих культурах особенно в казахской
культуры
когда же нет молодых пар не обязательно
показывать девушку а девушкой парня не
обязательно почему потому что женская
психика она гибкая
она приспосабливается вот девушку даже
до 60 70-летнего старика дай через год
каком городе лучше ее родном старика не
кого то ли он не будет оно пластично у
женщин идти к пластично она поживёт с
ним
ребенка родит все подгоню это самый
любим родной человек в а парень у парней
оси девушка не понравилось то все вот
сколько все не сможет не сможете жить не
может он не многозадачен короче трэйд
форма доктор нему жидкие в этом плане и
поэтому в этом тоже мы
с было у наших предков когда джин или
сначала есть ли тарда девушки
она ухаживала за столом это такие
смотрели если парню нравится после этого
они начинают вас вставлю процедуры
переговоров поэтому фильм низкие
терпения женщины спрашивали это
неравноправие но слушай наши предки но
за много веков выработали определенные
алгоритмы и процедуры как повысить
вероятность успешного брака против ну
вверх я вижу что
цинизм феминизм не до чего хорошего не
доводят посуда
люди конечно женщины становятся равна
платный но они стараются несчастной они
стали смещать потому что человек
становится счастливым только так и тогда
когда он выполняет свою миссию на этой
земле если женщина не родить ребенка но
все равно будете чувствовать опустошена
позже как или мужчина должен иметь как
можно больше детей тоже
а почему как вы думаете с чем связано то
что сейчас вот целенаправленно идет вот
это скажем так модно быть атеистом и не
модно верить в бога почему почему для
людей стало наоборот верующие это
какие-то далекие далекие там древние
австралопитеки а вот современный человек
это атеиста гностики тогда как вы
думаете откуда откуда ветер дует и зачем
это делается с людьми на самом деле
статистика это не подтверждает сейчас
муслимов уже больше миллиарда около
полтора миллиарда fucking ну
приближается то есть это какие-то
религии отмирают христианство например
сильно сдает свои позиции ну ислам бурно
расцветает чат и словам бурно расцветает
иная поможет всё равно штыки
воспринимают я вот когда ислам принял
мне там просто вообще там люди не важно
если ты общался с
алкоголиками и потом бросил был завязал
купить к теперь точно такое же было в
отношении среда не хочет отпускать не
обманешь поэтому здесь вопрос такое дело
в том что это все идет волна обратно до
в истории человечества было когда
фанатизм религиозны потом возрождения
расцвет науки как они говорят и так
далее были разные такие периоды так и
сейчас просто 20 века дал много много
научных открытий и человечество
почувствовала гордыню что все мы образом
забор тоса за бороду схватили и мы знаем
все мы знаем как устроен мир мы все все
в наших руках и так далее а сейчас мы
заглянули чуть-чуть за пропасть за
пропасть мы поняли что мы как обезьяна с
гранатой
создали такую вещь который может
уничтожить нас же самих то есть наши
достижения могут уничтожить нас же самих
есть и мы не начнем понимать другие
законы вселенной более высокого порядка
вот недаром большинство фундаментальных
физиков в конце жизни приходит пониманию
наличие бога есть такие физические
эксперименты k-lite там условно кот
шрёдингера да или там как эффект
наблюдателя дуал туале теория
частиц либо вот микрочастиц из которого
создан весь мире космос он freedns цу
времени может быть либо частицы
либо волной зависит от того есть
наблюдатель или нет это
и это физически доказано то есть в целом
а мельчайшая частица когда до нее дошли
и и начали как фотоны направлять и
поставили такую решетку и на той стороне
типа фотобумаге
для утрированно говорю и понятно что
наблюдатель думает что одолжит он полосы
дуть потому что то корешок действительно
на той стороны отпечатки получили а
самое интересно когда наблюдатели не
было пустили а потом чашка кофе взяли
бумаги контур
волны там были вон когда наблюдалась
метод опять полосы
то есть и ученые открыли не доказали что
самая элементарная частица этого мира
единицу времени одно и то же время может
быть как волна
так и частица чуть это нормально это
твердое вещество как может попробуем как
песчинка
а волна и тоже ничего так вот
человечество сейчас заглянула чуть-чуть
за тот край
вот сейчас этот кубик теле коронавирусом
тоже еще показывает ребята не все вы
знаете еще вы не все еще можете
управлять
свое время мы также заглянули за предел
когда была чернобыльской аварии
человечество осознало там когда там че
ты знаешь на чернобыльской войска ибо
взорвался на каждый час богу стал доску
выпускала столько радиации главный дом
big сброшенные на хиросиму каждый час
настолько мощное было родятся то есть
человек читает тогда прошло тоже
программе и поэтому просто после этого
20 века век просвещения новых технологии
тогда любите поймали гордыни
звезду поймать и вот этот час корона
веруйте что это один из способов
алмазных это люди начинают блудить
теряет свою истинную путь он просто
называет нам такие кризисы чтобы мы
задумались
чтобы мы задумались и вернулись на
правильную дорогу а почему вот человек
говорит зачем верить в бога достаточно
просто быть хорошим человеком для него
роста для него вернее для с точки зрения
удовлетворения его ежедневно батыры
пищей там чтоб совесть палаты это да но
человек такой состоят таком состоянии
может быть полностью счастлив ты знаешь
что убивая счастья счастью убивает страх
нам distract они мозга части работала
кристофф теперь ты отправил свою точку
учиться за границу
хороший человек как ты загородишь дочку
от несчастного случая на там не дай бог
посягательствами никак согласись у тебя
нету их алиментов ты хорошо деньги если
если можно ли это хранил компанию ладно
комитета но лет уже таких вещах
большинство соответственно у тебя все
время будет беспокойство по что-то по
беспокойство это легкая форма страха
единственный способ и ты не пусть и а че
чувствовать полностью счастлив
единственный способ быть полностью
счастливым и беззаботным
это понимать что аллах заботиться о тебе
и он никогда не сделает так что ты будет
плохо потому что ты поклоняешься ему
понимаешь и вот это ощущение она нужна
не столько самому аллаху сколько тебе
это нужно это важно не то русская это
уже бегал направляет для конечного лечит
вашу жизнь вашу
на поэтому но когда должен там дочками
ребенок за границы или в самолёте летит
ты за них помолился ты внутри полностью
уверен что все нормально будет
и это как раз тот случай когда вот это
элементарная частица вселенной она
решает быть волной или частицы и в это
время ты как наблюдать эту речь я верю
все будет хорошо обученную пока нет на
валах обещаю это как сказано что все в
положении верующего благо если его
коснулась что-то благо он благодарен
всевышнему если как сломать печаль он
терпит это тоже оборачивается благом а
вот я смотрю знакомый у меня там на
фейсбуке даже мало моя и я вижу страх
перед коронавирусом говорю мама вот все
что тебе предписано вот тебя ни больше
ни меньше вообще не коснется и тебе не
придёт ест суждено нам часто от
коронавируса дам полезность так и бурый
так что расслабься и вот реально
человеку по сути ну как я за себя тоже
понял что вера она дает спокойствие при
любых обстоятельствах
ему или хорошо или ему плохо там на
грани апокалипсиса кризиса он понимает
что все так как должно быть он нас по
куче просто вот он в процессе кстати
вот о процессе мы говорили он он спросил
он и он до последнего момента продолжает
быть счастлив до последнего вокруг всё
рушится пока lips он понимает и говорит
слова la
альхамдулилла он говорит что значит так
предписано это не все неспроста и так
далее вопрос очень важно
приобретений душевного спокойствия ни
один психолог вам это не даст это даст
можно только истинно вверх поэтому веру
biba убивай страх вера убивает сомнение
сомнения очень важны ваш что сомнения
это такие щелочки через которые
проникает вот этот мерзкий страх поэтому
и славный говорится не избегая
сомнительного избегая сам нет ни меня
это правило много раз спасал от всяких
вещей
даже в бизнес и когда там дословно мне
рашкин там ну какие-то приятные люди
предлагали делать бизнес
они всегда говорили там отдавая потом
разберемся я всегда понимал что никакого
потом надо надеяться многие обманываются
на эту я всегда говорю давайте на бумаге
пропишет права и бедность и тогда мне
говорит о чем мне не веришь иди отсюда я
терял понятно какие то возможности но я
избегал
потом рис как что у меня что видели
кинули там люди как-то не подставить
поэтому избегай сомнительным лучше всё
проговаривать все должно быть ясно пруду
да у меня тут все последние вопросы
остались уже это один из них как быть
хорошим отцом для своих детей что самое
важно ты знаешь как я до этого говорил
дети рождаются со своими талантами
наклонностями тогда на поэтому я считаю
первая обязанность отца это быть хорошим
пример потому что деятельность что не на
том что ты говоришь о том что они видят
как ты действуешь действуешь не тристан
соответствии с теми словами которые ты
говоришь не
если ты показываешь двойные стандарты то
все что бы ты ни говорил они никогда не
будете верить
поэтому не выпускай двойных стандартов
что делаешь что говорит что и делай что
говорю что игил и вот это очень важно и
1 обязан с это показывает хороший пример
обязанность наблюдать за эти за ребенком
я вот считаю что до 5 лет 6 лет
ребенка не надо трогать читы чтобы ему
не говорил он сильно то не усвоить он
только будет смотреть на то что ты как
ведешь себя то есть на твое поведение
дальше 6 0 5 6 лет до 1190 лет ты должен
ребенку предоставить максимальная
количество я возвожу шведский стол
различных занятий верховая езда
гимнастика математика шахматам улитка
там еще учета грозной кошки
робототехника войти и так далее почему
ребенка он все по маленькой попробовать
как шведский стол и ты должен определить
к чему и гнули вот тяга склонность если
у неё тяга к чему-то он на это западает
западает как только ты нащупал 23 такие
занятия на котором западает все с этого
момента
отсекает все лишнее и работаешь по
правильно был усилия с ними усиля я
сильная усилия 7
если он стремится к музыке там били
гимнастики он гибкий и у него получается
нанимая ему тренера по гимнастике
создавая условия высвобождаем и больше
времени для гимнастики
покупаем их форм этой гимнастики и так
далее у себя сильны почему очень важно к
родителю моменту окончания школы чтобы
ребенок четко понял свою миссию и свой
икигай для чего отошел на это цвет в чем
его сильная сторона в чем что он любит
важно чтобы ребенок четко понимал свои
цели что он любит что у него хорошо
получается и для чего чтобы этот мир вот
это основная задача родителя они
обучения английскому языку не впихивает
не но в тюрьме на различных цитаты
eublepharis и так далее
нет достаточно просто первый слой пример
второе шведский стол дать им попробовать
как можно больше колесо и замер третье
определение сильных сторон к его тягу к
чему
или мотивацию и 4 усилия сильная все и к
окончанию школы ребенок будет
замотивирован он будет четко знать чего
хочет кем он хочет стать
что он хочет что у него хорошо
получается и в чем счастлив все все цепи
момента ты знаешь ты сделал ребенка
своего счастлив ну как пишет а никакого
отношения имеют них деньгам и копию к
отпуску ни к чему то давайте я наверно
за включу комментария возьмем обратную
связь от людей ребят напишите пару
ласковых как вам вообще эфир сегодня
полезно не полезно понравилось не
понравилось
мы почитаем нам приятной ноте закончим
не слышно нормальный звук да да да
слышно сейчас смайлики доходит а мне еще
понравилось пример вы приводили про вера
в бога что это как игра в числа что типа
я вот верю даже если на всякий случай я
точно в итоге типа окажусь выигрыше а
если они верят сто процентов проиграю
вот можете пример понравилось это
это не пример это в свое время когда ко
мне друзья бизнесмен и говорили один
здесь известного бизнесмена и говорил
маргулан мурчит и зачем ты принесла нам
объяснили я ему улыбкой понимаешь дуру
ты от рисков ты а ты из давай возьмем
просто с теорией лист менеджмента ты же
как бизнес продолжу понимает рискнуть
года понимаем ну вот давайте вот
представим такую шкалу приз предположим
что бога нет если бога нет то мы оба
умрём мы будем гнить могиле согласно
согласен что я теряю я теряю то что всю
жизнь пять раз читал намаз
держал пост выплачивал закат небольшие
потери ну какие то не
всегда будет жизни мы оба проигрывает
там -1 минус 1
теперь представим что бог есть если бог
есть то ты улетаешь минус 100 ватт а я
улетаю в плюс тот теперь возьмем в рай
да ну покрайней шансы мне больше до
where возьмем результат моей игры у меня
либо -1 в его плюс то а результат твой
игры где а либо минус 1 либо -100 то
есть у тебя полностью игра lost нос
потеря потерь
поэтому гор даже с точки зрения
риск-менеджмента и рационального подхода
и тоже выгоднее и потом правда я через
какое-то время через год или два блез
паскаль был такой физик математик он это
первым выдумал и эта теорема до сих пор
она так и называется фирменный блеза
pascal
я учиться в жизни много раз убеждался
когда чуть такого потом всегда нахожу
какого-то автора который сто-двести
пятьсот лет назад этом уже пришел блин я
здесь дур вот это исторический плагиат
меня задолбал а теперь с какого-то
момента и как только у меня гениальная
идея меня посещает я победил заметку об
а значит и об этом направлении что-то
еще нет рассчитал искать а у него
обозначали у неё теория как раз именно
об этом что он математически выводит
выгодность веры бог кросса раза вот так
и называется теорема блеза pascal тоже
почитаю потом вопросов но они там
спрашивали что какие экономические
прогнозы 120 спросил экономические
прогнозы ближайшие полтора-два на
полтора-два года может на полтора года
мы скорее всего будем в условий кризиса
жить поэтому сейчас очень важно не
суетиться 2 наблюдать 3 не бояться 4
готовится готовится потому что
многие думают так сейчас во время
кризиса надо просто переждать
слушайте но если к окончанию кризиса вы
останетесь таким же человеком с таким же
мышлением с теми же привычками
то не фигня у вас не получится вы также
будете продолжать такую же жизнь
вот и пользуйтесь настоящим карантинными
кризисом для того чтобы подготовиться и
перейти на другой уровень и чтоб после
кризиса у вас была другая жизнь
поэтому возвращаясь опять к правилу лишь
теми вы никогда не решите проблему
находясь на том же уровне на котором да
и и создали
если хотите перейти на другой уровень
значит готовьте себя готовьте себя в
другом уровне ну вот на этой
оптимистичной ноте можно закончить со
супер спасибо большое за iherb матч
кросс ответа на большую рад был
познакомиться за вот здесь куча
подписывайтесь на у меня 4 crown то
инстаграмм фейсбук фетт игра и youtube и
в разных местах я даю разный контент в
основном
некоторый контент пересекается но в
основном я сразу пользуясь случаем
серьезно можешь разрушить и конечно
конечно
фейсбук я опубликую общественно
политические посты и всегда опубликовано
оказался на русском языке в обязательном
порядке в инстаграме я больше там упор
дела у нас жизненной историей различные
сентиментальные истории жизненные
истории но немного
общественно-политических вещей в
телеграме я даю свои комментарии по всем
живо тросом новостями и так далее идет
это путешествие это анализ прошедшей
неделе на казахском языке и тогда то
есть все четыре канала они у меня
полноценный так чтобы дублирует покажу
тупо дублирует нет они разные поэтому
пользуюсь случае я приманивают твоих
подписчиков к себе подписывайтесь весны
явным интересом буду рад с вами общаться
супер все тогда спасибо